so Colombia is that the only like
country you've gone to that I would say
is like developing
um I've been to the Dominican Republic
I've been to Costa Rica I think
considering like I think me first I've
been considering how big the world is
like to have such a like you know
generalized statement I think you would
like you would require traveling more
and just experience anymore so I think
because because it could become a
dangerous rhetoric to say that from
going to a few places and one of the
things you referenced was oh you could
check the index online I don't think
that's like a representative of how
those countries I could look like what's
going on over there like maybe you
should take a trip to more places and
just have a look